it's a further escalation in North
Korea's provocative missile testing with
one of the weapons suspected of being a
new type of intercontinental ballistic
missile that it has shown off at recent
parades
called the hwasong 17 it was also
famously featured in a promotional video
starring the country's leader Kim
Jong-un
fearing it was being flown over the top
of Japan as with previous tests Tokyo
issued an alert to some Northern
prefectures
I was surprised but thinking not again
we may have to think again about going
out fishing which will impact our
business
instead it's thought the missile may
have failed mid-flight Landing in the
sea separating the Korean Peninsula and
Japan
our analysis has indicated a possibility
that it would fly over the Japanese
archipelago and we issued a public
notice
the development of icbms capable of
reaching the continental United States
brought the Korean Peninsula to the
verge of war in 2017. Thursday's launch
seems to be sending a message to the U.S
ahead of its midterm elections in turn
the U.S has condemned the test calling
for U.N security Council resolutions
meant to prohibit North Korea's weapons
development to be more strictly enforced
on Wednesday North Korea launched
multiple salvos of short-range missiles
in protest at joint air drills being
staged by South Korean and U.S Air
Forces with one missile landing South of
the de facto Maritime border in response
South Korea fired missiles north of it
so it is North Korea making a very
violent protests to this specific aspect
of joint military exercises by U.S
forces in South Korea and South Korea's
Armed Forces
now in response to this icbn launch the
two allies have announced their military
exercises will be extended Rob McBride
Al Jazeera so